In late May of 2020,
when the death of George Floyd
sparked outrage across the United States,
it seemed like every major
corporation wanted to
"join the conversation",
including Apple, Twitter,
Sony, Amazon, Nike, Spotify,
YouTube, Facebook, Verizon,
Adobe, Zoom, T-Mobile, Alphabet, Nintendo.
You get the idea.
At one moment, all of corporate America
was trying to respond to this
moment of anti-black racism,
but there was one
company that really just,
their statement just
stood out among the pack.
And that was Ben & Jerry's.
It wasn't just nice platitudes.
It was actually legislation
that they were calling for.
But it's interesting if you go on
Ben and Jerry's Instagram
page or Twitter account
they're constantly
talking about these issues
and it's not just when they're prompted.
It's part of their actual mission.
What's going on is genocide.
And that mission
has been the cornerstone of
the brand for over 30 years.
But I will tell you-
Bernie, Bernie, Bernie.
But does Ben & Jerry's,
which in the year 2000 became a subsidiary
of a multinational corporate conglomerate
really care about social justice
or is it all just a clever
way to peddle more pints?
Hi, I'm Ben.
I'm Jerry.
You know, we may not have
the money to go on TV
for 30 seconds,
but we sure do make some
of the best ice cream
you ever tasted.
Look for us on top of every pint.
In 1978 when lifelong friends,
Ben Cohen and Jerry Greenfield,
opened their first ice cream
shop in Burlington, Vermont,
the brand wasn't focused
on activism per se.
We never called it a social mission,
but the business was values driven
from the earliest days.
I don't know that we were
hardcore hippies per se,
but we certainly believe
in peace and love.
So when we started as a
little homemade ice cream shop
our idea was to be a little corner store
that would be a community gathering place.
They would donate free ice cream
to nonprofit organizations,
people who are using the ice cream
to have celebrations or
for fundraising events.
The policy was not to turn down anybody.
They were basically
social justice activists
who had stumbled into making ice cream
and found that they had
a lot of success at it.
And as the years went on,
they became more and
more skilled and excited
to push various kinds of social causes.
Our feeling at the time
was that essentially
business is a machine for making money,
and that if we want to
be of as much service
to the community as possible,
what we need to do
is give away as much
our profits as possible.
And so we started The
Ben & Jerry's Foundation.
The Ben & Jerry's Foundation
would fund community organizations
and local initiatives,
helping disadvantaged
groups across the country.
And the foundation was to receive
seven and a half percent of
the company's pre-tax profits.
Which was the highest percentage
of any publicly held company.
The corporate average is
around one and a half percent.
I said 5%.
Ben said 10%, and we
settled on seven and a half.
You know, the investment
bankers, you know,
they were in disbelief,
because even 5% to them made no sense.
And soon the founders
began integrating their
activism into products
like Peace Pops,
a popsicle that would fund
a new anti-war charity,
an idea which in itself
caused some conflict.
There was always a tension
on the board of directors
between those who wanted to really commit
to pursuing social justice objectives.
And those who said no,
really what we got to do
first of all, is make sure that
we do a solid financial job
of selling ice cream,
that we have good profits.
But over time, the guys and the business
tried to figure out how to incorporate
the values of the founders
more into the day to
day business decisions.
And that was a real evolution
over a long period of time,
with some arguing back and
forth and some struggles,
but eventually led to the
creation of a mission statement.
That's based on this concept
that was called Linked Prosperity.
The idea behind Linked Prosperity
is that as the company prospers,
everything and everyone
it touches will prosper.
The company would have three goals
and the goals were equally important
and making a profit was
only one of the goals.
The second goal was
making the best quality
ice cream possible.
And the third goal was making
a significant commitment
to social justice and the
prosperity of the communities
that Ben & Jerry's served.
But the Linked Prosperity concept
wasn't entirely new.
The executives of businesses
in the '50s and '60s
were considered members of the community
and their businesses
were expected to support
their communities.
And they were looked down upon
if they did not participate as leaders
in the lives of their communities.
High up in a tower in Midtown Manhattan
are the offices of an unique organization,
devoted primarily not to making money,
but to giving it away wisely.
This started to change
really in the late 1960s,
early 1970s.
The change in attitude
was highly identified
with an economist named Milton Friedman.
I'm pleased to present the number one
selling book in America, "Free To Choose."
Please welcome the Nobel
Laureate in Economics,
Milton Friedman.
And Milton Friedman's position
was that the purpose of
business is to make profits.
If you do anything else besides making
as much profit as possible
with your business,
you're doing it wrong.
Just tell me where in the world you find
these angels who are going
to organize society for us?
Well, I don't even trust you to do that.
I studied that, you know,
in college and as an MBA,
I didn't believe it then
and I certainly don't believe it now.
I never envisioned the
integration of a social mission
into a business the way that Ben did.
I mean, I think he was really
visionary, but in my mind,
and certainly in Ben's mind,
there's no way for a business
to really be truly successful
if it's just focused on making money,
it needs to be mindful of
its other constituencies,
its employees, its immediate community,
the broader community, even the world.
And I think Ben & Jerry's
played an integral role
in hopefully putting to rest
Milton Friedman's famous quote.
Cementing the company's priority
has allowed Ben & Jerry's to integrate
more social activism into the company's
day to day operation, like
sourcing fair trade ingredients
even if it meant paying higher premiums,
partnering with socially
responsible suppliers,
like a bakery in Yonkers,
providing jobs to formerly incarcerated
and low-income residents,
campaigning against artificial
growth hormones for cows,
supporting LGBTQ rights,
promoting environmental justice
and more.
It was really about fairness and justice
and standing up for people whose
voices are often not heard.
And that's pretty different
from a corporate approach.
But I think making ice cream
allows us to talk with people
and connect with people
about serious things
in a pretty fun way.
As you give, you receive,
as you help others,
you're helped in return,
as your business helps the community,
the community supports your business.
Now that generated, you know,
a lot of favorable press,
which we think contributes
to people wanting to support
and buy Ben & Jerry's ice cream,
but it didn't originate
from people sitting
around in the marketing department saying,
hey you know, how can we
generate some more press?
Still over the years,
the values triad, product,
profit, and community,
proved to be a difficult
balance to maintain,
especially with increasing pressure
to compete with other super
premium ice cream brands.
As the company grew larger and larger
and the profit margins
grew smaller and smaller,
more of the shareholders of Ben & Jerry's
began to question the company's commitment
to spending extra money on
things like employee benefits
and charitable gifts and special
arrangements with suppliers
in tropical countries.
As a publicly held company,
you know, if your stock
price is not moving up
and you become an attractive takeover,
you're susceptible to that.
There were a number of
businesses that, you know,
expressed an interest in the company,
Ben and Jerry and a number
of people on the board
did not want to sell.
And they fought with the
other directors for 18 months,
but they eventually lost,
because not selling would
have meant laying off
probably 40% of their staff.
So they decided to sell to Unilever.
Unilever,
the multinational consumer
goods conglomerate,
owns Axe, Dove, Lipton,
and about 400 other brands.
The board was able to
negotiate a very unique deal
in which a unique Ben &
Jerry's board would remain
and they would have a say
in who the CEO that Unilever
put in place was,
and Unilever committed
to continue to donate
seven and a half percent to
The Ben & Jerry's Foundation.
And then there were some very dark years
when Unilever really
didn't manage Ben & Jerry's
very intelligently
and Ben and Jerry's has
sort of lost its way.
But about 10 years ago,
Unilever and Ben & Jerry's
renegotiated their
relationship and Ben & Jerry's
was allowed to fully recommit
to the three-part mission.
So when that happened, Ben
& Jerry's really took off.
And I think the company is
about four times as large
in terms of sales now,
as it was when Unilever
purchased it in the year 2000.
The Tonight Dough.
Some of the concepts that
Ben and Jerry spoke of
early on that investment bankers
you know, just, you know,
went white at, are now
part of the vernacular
in how businesses operate
today from the Fortune 500
on down.
Earlier this month,
Ben & Jerry's announced their support
for the Black Lives Matter Movement
Black Lives Matter members say
they question supporting businesses
who don't take stances against oppression.
There's a lot of data that shows
that customers are
really looking for brands
and companies to respond
to social activism.
And there was one stat
that really stood out to me
that two thirds of Gen Z
really look towards the brands
and how they respond to Black Lives Matter
and the way they react
will permanently decide
how they spend with them in the future.
I think the company was able
to speak out so strongly
and so clearly because it
had been doing the work.
And so that led up to
the George Floyd murder
and the company being able to say
we must dismantle white supremacy.
One of the most wonderful things
is that we had nothing to do with it.
People probably don't realize
Ben and I work at the company,
but we're not involved in the management,
we're not involved in operations,
we're kind of pretty faces, you know,
we're Ben and Jerry,
and the company came out very
strong and it was wonderful.
You can imagine how proud Ben and I are
that the company is
doing things like that.